OUTSTANDING PERFORMANCES IN
IN GAME FIVE, IN THE BACK AND
FORT
SCORES
ALLEADING, NINTH POINT,
THE TEAM THAT SCORED THE FIRST
GOAL IN EVERTHROUGH DON'T.
>> WANTING TO BE FOR LOS
ANGELES.
CROW PLAYED IN THE
N FACING
ELIMINATION.
ARCHIBALD LOST FOOTING.
>> A QUESTION WHETHER OR N.
YAMAMOTO.
IT GRIND IT.
OILERS.
>> PICK UP THERE BY TYSON
BACK
CECI.
AND A CROSS,R KANE'S STICK
ABLE TO GET LOOSE, GETS A PIECE.
KALIYEV SHOOTS,  GOTV WITH THE .
NOW, MOORE, ROY, BAC
REBOUND, CHANCE BY ROY.
AND DOES AND H RIGHT
THERE.
HEN FOR LEON DRAISAITL.
STUMBLES A BIT, BACK T T BACK-CS
THAT SEAM PASS.
NOT ON HIS STICK LONG.G.TRIGGER.
IT IS KICKED OUT BY SMITH.
NICE PAS THE DEFENEN
LIZOTTE. TRIGGER
HERE TYSON, AND
FLNER TO THE
FAR SIDE.
JUST LIKE THAT THE OILERS HOLDR.
LOOK TO QUICKLY RE-ATTACK HERED
UNBELIEVABLE LAST FEW GAME,
MAKES